-Ron Burgundy.
-What a wonderful ovation.
Jimmy, do you, uh...
Do you mind if I just
do some stand-up comedy?
-[ Laughs ]
If you'd like to.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, thank you.
That's what I'm talking about.
How's, uh...
How's everyone doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
What? Whoa!
What a crowd.
New York City in the house.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Am I right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
What does that mean, by the way,
"in the house"?
Are we in a house?
No, we're in a building.
A tall building that no one
would mistake for a house.
[ Laughter ]
New York City in the house.
How could 17 million people
fit in a house anyway?
[ Laughter ]
That's a lot of toilet paper,
if you ask me.
[ Laughter ]
What about an episode
of "The Real World"
that took place in a house
that fit New York City?
[ Laughter ]
Imagine binge-watching that.
You'd be 100 before you get
halfway through episode one.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-But these are the things
that keep me up at night.
[ Laughter ]
People like to say,
"Not in my house."
Well, of course not in my house.
I don't know you,
so I don't want you in my house.
[ Laughter ]
Am I right or what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
What else?
[ Laughter ]
You all having a good summer?
[ Cheering ]
Yeah.
Believe it or not, I've already
done all my Christmas shopping.
[ Laughter ]
I like to get it done
before Labor Day,
and I get everyone
the same thing every year --
A subscription to
"Playboy" magazine.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
Oh, sure, some people complain,
and I'll tell them, "Fine.
I'll just leave you off the list
for next year."
And they say,
"Wait! Wait, wait, wait!
Wait! Wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait!
Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait!
Just give me one more year."
[ Laughter ]
Am I right or what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Am I right?
[ Laughter ]
Show of hands -- how many
people here take the subway?
Hmm? Yeah.
[ Cheers ]
I love the subway
whenever I come to New York.
It's the only way
I get around town.
Yeah. You know, you ever take
the subway in the summertime
and you find the one car that is
empty and you think,
"Great. I'm gonna have
this whole car to myself,"
but once you get in,
you realize it is empty
because the air-conditioning
is broken?
[ Laughter ]
Well, I love
to hide in that car,
and when people realize
they picked the hot car
with the broken A.C., I pop out
and say, "Hey! Surprise!"
[ Laughter ]
"It's hot as [bleep] in here!"
"Because the A.C. is broken,
and that's why it is empty."
[ Laughing ]
"You got tricked!
Let's wrestle!"
[ Laughter ]
"It'll make the time go faster
for our journey."
Am I right or what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
We got any Yankee fans
here tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, Yankees.
For those of you
who don't know baseball,
the New York Yankees
are a big deal.
They're like the New York Jets
of baseball.
Just phenomenal history.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh...
No, it's true.
That's nothing to laugh at.
I like to sit out
in the right-field bleachers
with all the hecklers and yell
things at opposing players.
Really, really
get into their heads.
"Hey, number 12!
Why don't you go back to college
and finish your bachelor of arts
degree, huh?!"
[ Laughter ]
"There's really no excuse.
You could do it online
or take night classes."
[ Laughter ]
"Or go back to school
in the off-season.
Hey, Mookie Betts, you're a bum!
In between innings,
you should read --
use your time and read the
Mueller Report, unredacted!
I know you won't, though.
You know why?
Because you're a bum!
You're a no good bum!"
[ Laughter ]
Am I right or what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Baseball players, though.
There's a weird lot.
What else?
Uh...
Do we got any Shawn Mendes fans
here tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Don't like him.
Never have.
[ Laughter ]
First of all,
is he Canadian or Mexican?
Make up your mind.
You can't be both,
not in today's world.
No way.
Secondly,
he stole some of my songs
and my singing style
when he goes to that falsetto.
♪ Everything means nothing
if I can't have you ♪
Yeah, and I wrote that song
about Camila Cabello
because she broke my heart.
But now all the fans think
that he wrote it about her,
but he didn't!
I did!
I wrote the damn song!
I swear to you,
I wrote the song!
And now I'm the laughingstock
of the pop-music world,
and I want to tell you, Shawn,
one thing!
I don't like it!
It's bush league!
That's my time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪